I know what people that kind of are
weird after shows are the people that
have photos they say somehow went to a
you know they went to kink FedEx yeah
you bet and then in an old I print out
and there you go what name no just
saying your name but they sell it online
but really do I have to sign it then you
know they make they no don't no don't
as they did to fighters all time they do
yeah yeah man Rogan doesn't sign any of
those because of that he site actually
I'll take that back
he Rogan is very generous with that kind
of stuff but he will say to them because
they'll go he'll go assign one well you
can't give any sign seven of these
because he knows that they that they
sell them oh he goes dude listen I'm not
I'm doing this for a fan not so I can
you can have a career right that's not
okay because there's a there's a young
guy there that has a picture that wants
a sign or a thing that he keeps yeah but
then there's always a man with a manila
envelope with 19 in this one a Bobby
Bobby this one cuz I sell that [ __ ] and
by the way they make a lot of [ __ ]
make money over the dumb [ __ ] cuz you
want to my show I'll do it for free
no but people but but you don't get it
it go in a market of these kind of
high-res nice photos that they go out of
the red of print out yeah they sell them
for good [ __ ] money people want to buy
a nice picture that's signed by you cuz
it looks professional this is their game
oh I see are they interesting I've been
with a famous friend before I'm not
gonna say who I'll tell you how famous
very so week when we were at the airport
together whoa alright so many many many
humans wanted okay Peter I'm gonna go
crazy it's Russell Simmons it's not we
don't we don't really know we wasn't
making that you're not a comedian I love
you Russell famous person not a comedian
on comedian a big actor yes okay off a
billion people sign sign sign sign tiny
paper a picture sign sign please sign
sign sign sign the only thing the person
wouldn't sign was those things those men
though cuz he was like no that's a
[ __ ] scam yeah if a kid wants a photo
I'll take a photo yeah if I'm a grown
man has printed out photos to sell
online yeah no I'm not supportive and I
took and I learned
I was like oh that's what that that's
why I'm glad I [ __ ] said it now no
yeah don't don't don't don't
sign - probably a hundred of them yeah
yeah don't do that
also only made money off do you have a
regular signature do you have a nice
signature no mine's terrible but and I
really Bobby Lee or no really oh that's
cool it's almost like it's almost like
you just see be an owl
don't what yeah let me I'll do it on the
table yeah man this table will be worth
something someday so this is you know
what that looks like what are see ya RC
Cola what is yours and what is yours
look like terrible people start signing
the table yeah you know what I get
you're gonna do that yeah yeah by the
way you got to come back to whiskey jr.
and sign my picture cuz no knew it was
there after you were there please no Bob
okay whenever I go whenever I got a bank
and I have to sign my signature yeah I
get nervous cuz they're looking at me
yeah and I [ __ ] it up every time yeah so
I can't look at you when I do stars the
wrists are yeah hey people don't know no
yeah I don't want people to know who it
is you know because if I sign a bunch of
stuff and then one day when I die and
like someone slant they slander my name
I don't want it I don't want it like my
signature to also be sad you know I
don't want to see my name and be like oh
[ __ ] I wish she didn't sign this you
know what sometimes I don't give me the
pen yeah sometimes I do it but then I
yeah I'll do this I do this
[Laughter]
can I say something about signatures
yeah I'm stupid and I don't remember
what club it was but it made me get real
emotional comics where it's not we're
signing the wall in a club and I think
maybe it was good nights good shot I'm
good nights in North Carolina and it was
Robert Schimmel had signed one of the
bricks and I was like damn it's so crazy
like because we signed comics I knows in
most times when comics on green rooms
it's like something [ __ ] annoying and
they write some stupid bad joke yeah but
it was all these [ __ ] signatures and
his stood out for no reason that I was
like wow that's wild like that it was so
cool for some reason for people they
don't know Robert Schuman a little
[ __ ] comedian that passed away here's
another thing that I was at cap city
once I was in the greenroom I was
[ __ ] loved that Klaus sore subject
all right we won't talk about you
brought it up but anyway um I was there
was in a bad mood or whatever and it
looked up and they were at the top I
think on the ceiling in the corner was a
photo of Bill Hicks or something like a
headshot and it made me feel like Oh cuz
he used to play that role oh yeah so I
go okay I'm here for a reason
that's see those little things like that
see it is sweet yeah
[Music]